there's only death here
bodies of young russian soldiers lying
unclaimed
apparent victims of poor tactics
or so the ukrainians tell us
it was very intensive fighting our guys
had high morale a special operation was
planned together with a 90-second
brigade they flanked this position and
then cleared it
the russians had poor defensive
positions save their enemies exposing
them to ukrainian artillery this was a
russian defensive line
all along here
you have what's left over
of this intense battle burnt out tanks
weapons left behind
grenades
they didn't even have time to take some
of their dead
everywhere we look they are signs of
battle
and fear of chemical attack
ukrainian soldiers salvage what's left
the village of mother rohan is back
under ukrainian control but the cost has
been high
a fierce battle pushed the russians away
from the gates of kharkiv
21 year old eugenie has been awarded
ukraine's highest honor for destroying
five tanks and other heroics during
battle
he tells us it's the first time he's
come across the use of phosphorus the
highly flammable chemical
phosphorus
it was my first experience with
phosphorus air strikes were not as scary
as the phosphorus
first they used the air strikes then the
phosphorus
my eyes were burning i couldn't breathe
through my nose it was like really
difficult to breathe
the equipment
we can't independently verify its use
this was one of the main streets in this
village
and it's completely destroyed every
building
every window
everything that you see
has some sort of damage there's bullet
holes in the doors the windows have been
blown out there's bricks all over the
place and we've been told that we can
only stick to this main road
because everywhere around hasn't been
completely demined because the fear is
that the russians have left mines and
booby traps behind for the ukrainian
soldiers taking this place but as you
see
there's not much left
assad beg al jazeera
outside kharkiv